avec sociale vous devrez de zaccardo
d'exemplaires films comme philippe ils
sont soixante dix mille en france à
travailler en boucherie en supermarché
ou en laboratoire industriel le savoir
faire des artisans bouchers est très
demandé pourtant chaque année il manque
4 150 apprentis rien qu'en région
parisienne
le métier a du mal à séduire le plus
compliqué au début c'est de toucher la
matière première si on aime ce contact
ça va tout seul après après on va dire
que x est courageuse et par rapport au
nombre d'heures on va dire que
malheureusement d'apprentissage je crois
qu'il ya une moyenne c c'est six sur dix
qu'ils arrêtent la boucherie après
l'apprentissage qui sont écoeurés dans
les heurts la formation ces deux ans
d'apprentissage la base et puis après la
vie active directement mais toujours en
laboratoire au début pour préparer que
de la viande entre l'apprentissage est
passé à la vente
quand même 4 58 face à son entrée sur le
marché du travail un jeune boucher
gagnent en moyenne 1750 euros nets
les premiers salaires s'échelonnent
entre le smic et peuvent aller jusqu'à
2000 euros la journée commence tôt et le
travail est physique mais le métier
évolue comme l'expliquent philippe il a
tenu plusieurs boucheries et travaillent
dans ce secteur depuis 23 ans
nos anciens vendée beaucoup de viande
n'a travaillé pas que nous même temps
par contre on en vend beaucoup moins
mais par contre la clientèle est
beaucoup plus exigeante
photo soit travailler autant petits
soins les perspectives d'évolution
arrive rapidement en fin de carrière un
artisan peut toucher jusqu'à 6000 euros
net par mois
créer ou reprendre une affaire un pari
attractif lorsqu'on connaît le chiffre
d'affaires moyen par boucherie environ
370 mille euros dont 10 % de résultat
net
là vous avez des tubes pour faire cuire
donc on va faire cuire les tripes on
fait cuire le boudin blanc pour les
jeunes vaut mieux qu'ils apprennent plus
tôt la cuisine maintenant il y aura plus
de
entraîneur quand charcuterie
l'engouement actuel pour la gastronomie
les métiers de bouche et le bio
participe à remettre au goût du jour ce
métier en 2013 les inscriptions ans et
ap boucher ont augmenté de 15%